how have you been Chris what's up man
how are you I'm great how are you doing
I'm great you know we got a day off
tomorrow so that's always good and camp
is a lot easier nowadays after you know
the CBA changed so what before we get
into the current let's let's stroll down
memory lane a little bit here Oh what's
your memory of your dad in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame Chris you know I
would say you know it's pretty young I
was maybe 12 13 years old but uh just
kind of you know as I said before my dad
and my mom never pushed on me as far as
how great my dad was at the sport he was
real humble about it
and you know when he came home he was a
dad he wasn't how he longed be you know
perennial Pro Bowler he was you know
just our dad so for me I sporadically
watched him play while he was playing
you know I can remember being in my
buddy's house when they were playing the
AFC Championship game in Buffalo and we
take like lengthy breaks to play Sega
Genesis like I was missing most of the
game and you know I should be glued to
the TV watching my dad but you know that
was a product of he didn't really kind
of impose his greatness on us and then
you know when he when he retired and
those things started happening and I
started watching more of his film I was
a lot more cognizant of how great he was
and even now when I watch tape of him
I'm really impressed he was kind of like
ahead of his time a little bit the way
he played and the multitude of positions
he played so that was a special weekend
for him I know coming from nothing and
coming from you know out of nowhere as a
player he's reached Heights that you
know anybody would want to reach well
how does the fact that he didn't make it
about football when he came home and was
in front of you and the rest of the
family how did that shape you into the
person I did you think I just think you
know the best thing a parent can do that
plays in the NFL a dad can do is you
know hopefully teach his kid that
they're not special for any reason other
than you know what they bring to the
table and how they treat people you know
you're not just born special because you
know your dad played in the NFL or
anything like that
you know we're
a special family we're lucky you know my
you know my dad played a game for a
living and made money doing it and you
know my son Waylon he'll learn that you
know what I did for a living doesn't
define who I am and it doesn't make us
special so you know hopefully it just
taught us a little humility and you know
just context of you know you need good
breaks to make it and a lot of hard work
as well but you know knowing how hard
this game can be and how many great
players didn't get all the good breaks
that made my dad did or somebody who who
gets to play 1011 years in a league it
takes a lot of luck too so having
humility along the way with your success
yeah you pointed Chris long entering an
eleventh year in the National Football
League why do you play then Chris what
do you what do you think you saw it's a
hard thing to quit it's you know as a
competitor you always feel like you your
best ball is still ahead of you and you
know there were two years where I got
hurt a lot and my career was really
rolling before that and I feel like I
just still have a chip on my shoulder
where I'm trying to reprove myself and
you know 33 you know I still I still
feel good I'm having a good camp and you
know last year I was able to pressure
the quarterback at a really high rate
and I always feel like I can get better
and I want to be a part of what this
team does because this is one of the
most special teams I've been on and and
we got great guys in the locker room I
loved playing the city of Philadelphia
that would be a hard thing to walk away
from after everything that the city went
through last year on on the positive end
of things to walk away after that I mean
this city was unbelievable and and
that's my favorite part about playing
for the Eagles is playing a Philly Chris
long Philadelphia Eagles defensive end
again here care of Applebee's which
we'll talk about in a second here on the
Rich Eisen show live from the Pro
Football Hall of Fame
you're a perfect got asked a couple of
things of current NFL storylines that
are going on that we hear stories about
one of them is
that is not fun to play in New England
we've heard that well I mean you know
Amendola leaves he goes to Miami well
that's not I mean maybe cold temperature
wise but it also may be cold you know
yeah well I'm sold like when the Sun
Goes Down early I mean those those are
my biggest gripes I mean I don't mind
cold weather that the Sun Goes Down at
like 4 o'clock in the afternoon
now you seems like you're trying to cut
me off before I ask the question Chris
because you're a very smart guy but it
also came from your locker room during
the Super Bowl last year's like hey it's
more fun here it's not fun there
Amendola leaves he goes to Miami he
makes mention of how it's less fun
sometimes to play in New England what
are your thoughts on that subject
playing for my thoughts are coming from
where I've come from and I loved every
not every minute of playing in st. Louis
obviously when your team doesn't win any
more than 7 games in a season for 8
years I mean you know I played on 1 of
15 teams I played on 2 of 14 teams I
played in front of 10,000 people because
the teams moving and you know we're not
playing well I've been beaten 44 to 3
you know I've been beaten 51 to 7 like
that's not fun so you know for me to go
someplace like New England from that
situation and you have an opportunity to
win a Super Bowl other than the Sun
going down at 4 o'clock in the afternoon
you know and the scheme not fitting me
perfect I really enjoyed my teammates
and I enjoyed coming to work there I
mean every part of being in the NFL is
complaining guys you know guys sit
around and complain and and we we
complain about you know schedule being
too long like you know the meetings are
too long practice was too long today
that's universal wherever you go and
there's different ways to to get the job
done and every organization does things
differently but I I had more fun than I
didn't in New England and you know I
really will cherish those memories as
long as I live Chris long here on the
Rich Eisen show and then obviously the
other subject that's going on and with
the NFL is the anthem rule and what's
been going on
obviously from Pennsylvania Avenue and
then the state of Pennsylvania with the
invitation and not invitation what has
it been like for you Chris long and your
teammates to read the headlines and be
mentioned in the headlines and in tweets
what has this whole process been like
for you well it really hasn't been hard
I mean we're really close team and you
know there's certainly guys with
different political leanings or whatever
that's the NFL arm but there I can't
think of one situation in our locker
room where there's been like you know
tension or a disagreement you know we
all love each other we we've
accomplished a lot together and we've
and we've done a lot and you know we've
got a lot left to do as a team and so we
honestly it sounds boring and cliche but
we think about football and when it's
time to answer questions and stand up
for our beliefs we can do that too but
you know when we're at work and we talk
about a host of issues that have nothing
to do with football in the lunchroom or
in meeting rooms but you know this is a
brotherhood and you know when it's time
to work it's time to work so you know in
training camp all those distractions go
away and to be honest most of the time
they're not even distractions to us when
we read about possible distractions or
you know is the White House thing you
know a distraction for the Eagles it
couldn't be further from a distraction
in our building we're really tight team
and you know a lot of that stuff is
media created and and until we show that
we that we falter because of something
like that I don't think it's fair to say
you know that it's a distraction for us
or it's made it harder on us I mean
we've gone about our business as a tight
and tight-knit group and worried about
our job or all on occasion President
created because I mean I mean yeah well
the Eagles the Eagles did not kneel
during the national anthem last year
right and so I mean ya know the only
part the only parts of stuck out that
really that really even surprised me by
by those standards was when a news
network ran you know footage of guys
praying in the endzone
/ as b-roll for a segment about how the
Eagles are unpatriotic and and did all
this kneeling and stuff not that you
know kneeling is unpatriotic but you see
what I'm saying so I mean it just got so
ridiculous at a point but in our locker
room we don't feel that I mean we don't
we that doesn't even register you know
in our locker room conversations it
doesn't register you know in the vibe in
the locker room we don't watch TV you
know we're not worried about what people
are speculating might be the mood in the
locker room or our mood in our locker
room is is always sky I mean we are a
really tight group and we've been
through a lot and we've accomplished a
lot and we want to do more so and one
last question for you before we hit on
Applebee's is that the new helmet rule
that we saw last night draw three flags
where you're not supposed to lead with
your helmet and hit somebody and what
happened in your locker room potentially
with a disagreement amongst officials
what happened there oh no I mean you
know we always in any I felt locker room
you're gonna have an officials meeting
before to kick-off the year and a lot of
times the competition committee has come
up with some new rules and there's going
to be you know changes made and you know
NFL's trying to stay out of the curve
with the with the safety stuff and
obviously NFL wants the offenses to
prosper in our league so a lot of
defensive players when we get you know
kind of handed these new rules you know
without a say we don't love it you know
it's not just the helmet rules there's
some rules about you can't land on the
quarterback with all your weight or most
of your weight right that's me Anthony
bar rule yeah which is the answer the
Anthony bar rule pretty much right yeah
I mean it's hard man I mean listen I
know the NFL's trying to do the right
thing safety wise sometimes in there
there's always going to be a little bit
of hysteria and there's always going to
be a you know a time frame where people
don't know exactly what's going on but I
think by the middle of the year maybe
even the first quarter of the year it'll
be a little
more predictable and people kind
understand what's the actual threshold
for calling some of these penalties I
think some of them are guidelines and
and they won't be called to the letter
of the law always I hope and what and
what is the what are the guidelines and
rules of team chicken tenders vs. team
riblets well I think in the summer when
the temperatures are up around 100
degrees I like a lighter fare and you
know for me that's chicken tenders all
day long and Applebee's you know when my
brother and I shot the Applebee's
commercial and he was eating riblets and
I was eating chicken tenders it was like
8:00 in the morning I probably ate 26
chicken tenders I'm not lying to you and
and they were delicious it was a great
breakfast it was light it was crispy and
I think you should get down to
Applebee's by the 12th here coming up
because that's when the special ends at
Applebee's it's it's it's a lovely place
and and the chicken tenders are
delicious fantastic all-you-can-eat
ribbits and chicken tenders they're back
at Applebee's before I let you go tell
me about water boys what's the latest
with this one Chris thank you for having
rich water boys as you know it's my
clean water initiative where we do large
sustainable solar-powered wells and in
East Africa primarily but we're getting
ready we're gearing up to do some
domestic stuff this year which is really
exciting because people are always
asking you know what are you doing in in
America so more to come on that but I'm
very excited about it we have funded our
45th large solar powered well and as
soon as that's in the ground we'll have
160,000 people drinking clean water from
our our wells
we finished our really successful
Kilimanjaro climb with our wounded
veterans and retired players this past
February and there'll be the NFL Films
is doing a documentary on it and that
will be coming out in the fall so I'm
really excited about that you know
hopefully the platform is improving and
people can check it out at Waterboys org
yeah I water boys org it's a great
organization I'm glad to hear that
you're doing stuff domestically you know
with what went down in Flint Michigan
when we were and DC for the Baseball
Hall of Fame that we were being told to
boil water potentially while we're down
there so drinking waters a serious
well another fun thing we open to fund
immediately to try to you know we
pitched in and open to fun but it didn't
gain much traction I think that's sad I
think we can all do better domestically
and you know our infrastructure has got
to improve and so we'll hopefully shed
some light on some some potentially
avoid in the next flynn use our platform
to ask the right questions and push
people to to you know do a little self
inventory on our water here in the
States
of course you're the best thanks for
calling in we'll chat soon hopefully
thanks a lot man you bet Chris long at
Joel number nine 1o any on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience